Always keep in mind that in both cases,
the while loops and for loops.
Our loop counter, is just a variable just like any other variable.
We usually call it i for simplicity,
but we could always call it any other name.
The same goes with our loop increment.
This can be any mathematical operation that we can normally do to an integer.
Let's have a look at a few common ones.
The most commonly used one i++,
which is just a shorthand of i = i+1.
And that simply adds 1 to an i.
Say, for example, our i was equal to 10,
i++ would change that to 11.
We've also seen i--,
which is just a shorthand of i = i-1,
and it basically subtracts 1 from i so if i was 10,
that would make it 9.
Now, we can step up faster than just adding one or subtracting one.
Remember when we used to add numbers to a variable just by
saying i = i+5 or whatever number,
this can be shorthanded into i+ equals that number.
They both mean the exact same thing.
In this case, it's just adding 5 to i and updating i into that new value.
Say, if i was 10,
that would end up updating i to 15.
Similarly, goes with i minus a number.
If we say i = i-6, for example,
this can be shorthanded into i- = 6.
Meaning that if i was equal to 10,
it would update it to 4.
The exact same goes with multiplication and division.
We could update a variable by multiplying it with a number like so.
i = i*3 so that multiplies i by 3 and updates i to that new value.
The shorthand for that is i* = 3 just like plus and minus.
If i was equal to 10 that will multiply it by 3 and update it to 30.
The same goes for division as well.
We can divide our variable by a number like so.
i = i/2 that would divide our variable by 2 and update its value to that new calculation.
The shorthand for that is i/ = 2.
In this case, if i was 10,
it will divide it by 2 and update it to that, which is 5.
Let's have a look at a few examples that use those shorthands.
Let's say you want to print only the even numbers between 2 and 10.
Basically, you want to create a loop that starts from 2 and counts
all the way up to 10 but instead of adding 1 to our loop counter,
we want to increment it by 2.
We've written a function here called even
numbers that doesn't accept any parameters and it doesn't return
anything so it's called public void evenNumbers empty brackets and then curly brackets.
Inside, we only have this loop here that starts with the loop counter
i=2 and it keeps counting as long as i is less than or equal to 10.
But our loop increment is i+ = 2.
This instruction here adds 2 to i every time so every iteration in our loop,
i jumps by 2.
Let's trace this and see what's happening.
The first thing i gets initialized to value 2,
and i is less than or equal to 10 so that's true.
We step inside our loop and we do
this print line operation which prints out i as it is, which is 2.
We reach the end of our loop so we go back
up and the first thing we do is our increment here.
Our increment adds 2 to our loop counter i,
and it was 2 making it 4 and then we
do our comparison i less than or equal to 10 which is true.
And so we step into the loop and printout i again which is just 4.
We step back up,
we add 2 to our loop counter which makes it 6 and 6 is still less than or equal to 10,
so we print out 6.
Go back up, add 2,
8 is still less than or equal to 10, so we print out 8.
8 becomes 10 and 10 is still less than or equal to 10 so we print out 10.
We've reached here, we go back up and that adds 2 to our loop counter making it 12.
12 is no longer less than or equal to 10 so that's false,
and we don't step into the loop anymore.
So we don't print anything else.
Once we change our loop increment from just i++ to something like i+ = 2,
you can see that i is increasing in steps of 2 rather than 1.
You could also change this to i+ = 3,
for example and that would grow in threes.
Remember that you could also use the multiplication like i* = 2,
which means that every time i would get multiplied by 2 rather than just add 2 to it.
There's a lot you can do with all these operations.